um just because you might have different
opinions in politics why people will
I don't know it's just it's just it's a
cult yeah it's a lack of courage in this
country but it's like it seems like it's
when people get afraid when they start
to panic is when the politics becomes
divisive if they're not in a panic state
right I've never noticed that in the
last 40 years right you're absolutely
fun it's actually fun to talk politics
yeah yeah and that's why I think your
story your guys's story is so important
here because you know you guys also had
that fear before coming on and actually
being the truest versions of yourselves
being actually authentic not being
afraid to actually speak your mind and
once you're living freely there's
there's the kind of softness there's a
kind of easiness going around life being
like hey I'm not gonna have to you know
think about what I'm gonna have to say
here I'm just gonna say what I want you
to say living that life is amazing and
sadly a lot of people listening to this
right now are holding themselves back
they're afraid to say anything they're
afraid to intervene they're afraid to
have those conversations and I think
they're being stupid